à sylvie joly dans coke a déclaré je
suis votre idole jusqu'au 6 juin 2007
jean bayle sur le dit votre âge non
blancs fou j'ai 17 ans ah bah voilà
la belgique se délite dollar a évolué
d'une famille catteau bourges
bah oui vous vous montrez des cvg mon
père officier de marine
charline il était marine marchande son
père pendant ce soir famille assez
traditionnel où il est pas bien vu
d'autres artistes cercle par est pas du
tout à supporter d'être artiste
professionnel way artistes comme ça ça
va
voilà c'est vrai quand on sait quand on
avait un talent caché dans la famille de
sylvie joly fallait exercer en secret
voilà un amateur en amateur est il votre
arrière grand oncle lui par exemple et à
la comédie française
le père c'est bien par des non mais sans
rire c'est à dire que ça c'était le fret
on est un grand mère qui était à la
comédie française avec un pseudonyme et
ils étaient cinq enfants et quand on
demande à mon arrière grand mère comme
il ya vous aviez
cet enfant elle disait 4 sur les photos
de famille il ya une tache d'encre à la
place de ce tome loi a changé quand même
regardé comme à morgane elle fait d
ixelles décembre ses parents avec son
jury
bon voilà papa maman on a décidé avec
grec de faire du x mais mes enfants ce
par un problème ça a changé quand même
parce qu'à l'époque de 6,10 à la comédie
française c'était mal vu des sous on est
content si l'effet du xv a trop vous
dites alors un truc un peu quand même un
peu gonflé quand même vous dites il est
plus difficile de s'imposer quand on
vient d'un milieu aisé
oui je crois que c'est moi je suis
d'accord et que c'est ça le cvo oui
viviane hamy les aristos et moi je
n'arrive pas à pleurer sur l'enfant
d'une famille aisée même quand il est
contrarié c'est précisément ça qui est
dur c'est qu'on pleure pas sur ces
précise celle qui tourne locales à
l'école le gosse de riche moi j'aurais
jamais voulu être à cause de rues jusque
le gosse de riche à lui dit attends tu
vas quand même pas de plaindre hein tes
parents il semble un gagnant et où
souvent il a tout sauf l'amour
il a beau sac et labo sac en cuir il a
des beaux stylos mais il a pas d'amour
et celui là il faut que les malheureux
que que des enfants de deux bons rendre
qui n'a pas d'amour évidemment et qui
est malade
alors location comique assez précoce
vous dites je suis né clown et comme
vous êtes croyante
vous avez considéré très tôt votre
vocation c'était un deux voire d'une
certaine façon d'exploiter votre talent
comique c'est une espèce de volonté
mystique pour faire du bien aux gens oui
c'est vrai à un moment donné je me suis
dit bah oui c'est vrai que sur ce
dernier on a l'impression qu'on est doué
pour quelque chose et que ça s'est dit
pas du mal aux gens rient bien oui
exactement
alors étant enfant vous a été envoyé de
cette institution religieuse et vous
êtes retrouvés dans la classe de
bernadette chirac a été comme on
connaissait déjà les pièces jaunes un
événement non elle était une élève bonne
elle bonne élève
ouais ce qui était facile ce sens par
rapport à l'or après le bac vos parents
vous interdise de devenir actrice et
votre père vous dit puisque tu veux tu
exprimes et a4 avocate et dans la douche
choisissez celui qui habite le plus près
de chez vous c'est maîtrise horny vous
saviez quand même que ça a été l'avocat
de pétain et tout ça oui oui oui vous
allez après on peut être l'avocat de
pétards marquer mais tout le monde a
droit à un avocat mais il avait quand
même des idées à ses actionnaires m
isorni non c'est pas moi je veux tout le
monde hein et didier contradictoires moi
j'ai connu une journée il était tombé
amoureux de son client
ouais ce qui arrive là est vraiment un
j'avais des bouquins ce 6 mai il était
fasciné par l'homme qu'il a mais qu'il
avait défendu ouais alors réalisé qu'au
delà des effets de manche
il est comme de tonne de paperasse dans
ce boulot d'avocat et puis la
responsabilité puisque vous dites si je
fais pas rire à soir c'est pas grave
mais s'il mais qui prend dix ans parce
que j'ai mal plaidé s'emmerde encore que
ça puisqu'elle va la peine de mort zilla
j'ai oublié un truc tout les face à vous
un peu plus de responsabilités bon pour
moi je m'appelle
on est marié depuis sept ans pour vous
annoncer à votre mari finalement voulais
être comédienne
si vous avez ça vraiment chevillée au
corps quoi et votre mari d-will je
savais que tu étais artistes vous êtes
vraiment oui c'est assez vrai c'est une
chose j'ai du mal quoi alors jouer il
faut dire que jenny bas vous avez du mal
à personne de 40 ans qui est avec vous
mais où même un peu puis à la magie
libyen vient au spectacle ils veulent un
beau spectacle
irie alors comment vous voyez votre mari
rires c'était ne veut pas dire qu'il est
le seul à se mettre d'accord parce que
je veux dire ça nous encourage c'est
normal non sélectionné mais j'ai souvent
âgés chaque fois que j'ai vu sylvie
j'étais à côté de son mari respire avec
celui qu'ils veulent de toute façon si
les est pas là moi j'aurais j'aurais pas
fait ça je ne serais pas arrivée un
ouais c'est trop dur c'était ce soir
c'est dire la culture
vous êtes une fille courageuse parce que
quand vous décidez de devenir donc
comédienne vous pourrez des causes au
cours simon faisait l'école de tanis
abacha bas j'avais l'école de tabia
balle lâchée au 20 mai
je suis arrivé j'étais courageuses comme
puis à un vrai nom mais si vous prenez
des cours avec avec le cours simon par
exemple d'aller au petit conservatoire
de la mia whitta njawe à la tania tenir
le cheval à jouer du classique au départ
jouer le jeu des secousses ne s'est pas
préparé des scènes question est ce que
je pouvais pas passer largement dépassé
l'âge jusque là vraiment serré aux
coursives où j'avais trente 30 berges
donc enfin que je fasse elle est passée
célimène et ça ça marche pas je rien
[ __ ]
le début des années 70 ce que vous
décidez la carrière comique
alors là oui c'est allons-y essayons
sagala que je fais ça me fait plaisir
c'est magnifique avec des rideaux bleus
voient comme une sorte de paradis c'est
pareil on l'a fait a levé juste avant et
oui le secret quand même s'est jamais
cherché à être drôle parce que là c'est
fichu c'est oui c'est non c'est vrai je
pense pas que c'est ce que je crois
c'est pense la même chose que si on est
ici on est surpris en flagrant délit de
vouloir être drôle c'est moi bien que
d'être directement drôle bien à l'école
sylvie joly au caire jeudi
le spectacle au casino de paris jusqu'au
16 janvier à mes yeux